the jurgen experience when you were
thinking about doing this what made
clean water what made that the thing
that you chose to to have as your main
charitable
organization so i was living in
australia
and they were experiencing a like
a pretty significant drought and
australia is very developed it's
um and to see the major headlines to see
the rules like oh you can't water your
your grass right now you can't wash your
car right now and just to see
that happening and somewhere so
developed it had it in the back of my
mind
like wow water isn't something that
should be taken for granted and it isn't
just this unlimited
resource and so i was studying
environmental science and i remember one
of my professors mentioned
that the wars of the future would be on
water like
and and in some countries it's already
the case and to me
that was kind of like that one sentence
that i couldn't unlearn i couldn't stop
thinking about
and it just hit me at a core
of like that is so wrong and
i yeah i was 19 or 20 and um
at that point i felt like i had like a a
little bit
because of traveling like i had a little
bit of a sense of what was going on in
the world
but to know at that point one in six
people didn't have
clean water i was like wow i didn't even
know
about one sixth of our planet and what
their daily struggle is and like
the fact that it's a problem that has a
solution
and it's something that like
i don't know what cause could have
as big as an impact as water because you
think like okay
if you wha what can you live without
um you can't even survive three days
without without water so
and just like thinking about health half
of the hospital beds are filled because
of unsafe drinking water if you think
about environment if you think about
education
um half of the hospital beds in the
world is that what you mean
yeah and like half yeah
like um the for children
in the world the greatest killer is
diarrhea
diarrheal disease and that is because of
unsafe drinking water and that is
like i there's this documentary
that came out recent well within the
last year called i think it's brave blue
world and matt damon
um shared something at the at the
beginning about like
imagine that right now we find the cure
for all childhood cancers and then
imagine in 50 years from now
these kids are still dying from this
very cancer that we have a cure for and
that is what's happening with clean
water and
i mean if you it just i don't know it
still
boils my boils my blood just like
thinking about like how
wrong it is and when you when you see
how wrong it is i mean i i feel like
of course i would want to support that
and
and do something and like when i first
started learning about it i was i
the first water project i was able to
fund was in haiti and i was learning
about how
some places they don't even name give
their kids a name
until they're five years old because
okay so who's affected by the water
crisis women and children children their
bodies
aren't strong enough to withstand and to
fight back
all the bacteria and like viruses and
all the
um things yeah exactly so
so they won't even give their kids names
until they
they think they'll be able to to live
right so like just
thinking about that is like these are
these are real people like these are
i don't know i i real people today yeah
exactly
5 000 years ago and like just the idea
of not even giving your child a name
because
of that fear of like they might not even
live so you don't even want to
get like my friend lex lex friedman yeah
he's a scientist that works with
artificial intelligence he posted
something on his instagram
it's uh yesterday it's a crazy statistic
about um children and infant mortality
from
i believe was 200 years ago
look at this in 1800 43
died before the age of five today it's
four percent
just imagine that and that was all over
the world 43
but that's not the case everywhere yeah
obviously if you're not naming your kids
it's probably uh that's probably where
the gap is because it's not
five percent of american children die
before that age
yeah catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience